[Music]
on this sunday night
defying the kovit 19 rules
[Music]
the car rally that put hundreds at risk
they basically took over
the community plus the hundreds
potentially exposed at a restaurant
in a province with climbing cases the
success story
how the atlantic bubble is allowing
classes to go ahead
as normal the who's dire warning
as the global kovid 19 death toll
approaches a terrible milestone there is
a lot that can be done to save lives
the real question is are we prepared
connectively
to do what it takes and mini moon
the object headed into earth's orbit
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with new signs of trouble
in canada's fight against kova 19.
despite repeated public health warnings
and efforts to slow the resurgence
infections are still spiking in canada's
biggest provinces
over the past 24 hours nearly 900 people
in quebec
tested positive that's the biggest jump
since early may
ontario also reported a major spike
today 491 new cases
there were 51 new cases in manitoba and
15 in saskatchewan
out west the most recent daily case
numbers are from friday
when there were 153 cases in alberta and
98 in bc
canada's chief public health officer is
urging everyone to reduce our contacts
and take every measure possible to help
slow the spread of the virus
before it gets out of control but some
people just aren't getting the message
in ontario for the second weekend in a
row police were called in
after hundreds of people ignored
warnings and gathered for a car rally
global's catherine ward has tonight's
top story
it's just a recipe for a people getting
sick or people getting injured or killed
police and politicians had a heads up an
unsanctioned car rally was a possibility
in wasaga beach ontario this weekend but
they had no idea how many people might
actually attend saturday they got their
answer there was a smoke show
squealing tires people walking with
cameras in amongst the
the traffic on the roads there was
literally
no control of the situation for officers
it was a flashback to one week ago when
another
unauthorized car rally took over the
parking lot outside a movie theater in
ancaster
they say organizers of that event could
face a ten thousand dollar fine
but so far no one has been charged back
in wasaga
tire marks on the road are just some of
the evidence of what took place
officers handed out several tickets for
driving offenses and for breaking the
pandemic
gathering limits imposed by the province
at one point the town was effectively
shut down
and no one was allowed to enter unless
they were a resident
police say for large rallies like this
one it's a challenge to hold every
single person
accountable it's difficult for us to get
a handle on it
because just the sheer numbers i mean
it's a takeover mentality
and they do they take over and overwhelm
law enforcement with just your numbers
doctors say if meetups like this
continue
it will only make the fight against
covid19 more difficult
you know this far into the epidemic to
put put on a mask
to spread apart by two meters to wash
your hands to avoid large crowds
and we sort of think about that
checklist we sort of see some
significant errors on from on many of
those points with
that gathering yesterday what experts
say they know is that simply
telling people to follow the rules won't
necessarily work
they say a lot more effort and resources
needs to be put
into crafting messages that stick most
effective way for people to follow the
rules
is if the rules are sort of given to the
people over the long term
so that they're able to sort of absorb
them internalize
them rather than point fingers and play
the shame and blame game i really think
that we need to take a step back and
reevaluate
how we're communicating these messages
the modes of communication
until that happens police say they plan
to do everything in their power to find
those responsible
so rallies like this continue to be
discouraged this investigation isn't
isn't over just because the cars have
left with sega beach this will be
ongoing of people examining video and
identifying drivers and
trying to figure out who the ringleaders
are katherine ward
global news toronto in toronto around
600 people are being told to monitor for
symptoms
after potentially being exposed at a
downtown bar
public health officials released the
warning today after three staff members
at the regulars bar
tested positive yesterday officials
warned that five staff members and two
patrons at a restaurant on yonge street
tested positive in that case 1700 people
have been told to monitor themselves
for two weeks canada's atlantic
provinces are keeping new cases
at bay the four provinces new brunswick
nova scotia prince edward island
and newfoundland and labrador created a
bubble at the beginning of july
monitoring and restricting movements in
and out of the region
now as ross lord reports that move has
allowed university students
to head back to class with some normalcy
saint francis xavier in nova scotia is
doing something most canadian
universities only wish they could
emulate
offering most classes in person we came
to a balance of 70 percent face-to-face
and 30
of our classes online president andy
haykin
says saint-effects leads the country in
preserving old school education
a distinction made possible by the
atlantic bubble a collective effort by
nova scotia
new brunswick prince edward island and
newfoundland and labrador
to monitor and restrict travel in and
out of the region
as the virus rolls through canada
accelerating the number of new cases
the atlantic region is mostly covert
free it's become normal for each of the
four provinces to go days or even weeks
at times
without any new cases a key part of
state effect's plan
is testing every student arriving from
outside atlantic canada three times
whether they have symptoms or not it's
monetary at the moment to wear masks on
campus
we've had a good campaign going called
neva helping help helping neighbors
and what is what that does is to remind
students wear the mask
wash your hands and social distance when
you're on campus
more than two weeks after classes
started there are no outbreaks
giving students bragging rights with
their families well i tell them i made
the right decision coming out east
instead of staying in ontario
as long as everybody's wearing their
masks and keeping distance then it's not
too bad as long as people are following
the rules
there have been violations and a small
number of students fined for failing to
self-isolate after coming to campus
but officials say santa fex's location
in the fairly isolated town of anaganish
helps its odds of suppressing the virus
we're saying to our students
if you don't have to travel outside of
antigonish don't do it
and that's the message we're putting out
for thanksgiving as well guarding
against complacency
while enjoying success ross laura global
news
era ganesh nova scotia the serb which
served more than 8 million people over
the past six months has now come
to an end canadians still needing
financial assistance have to transition
to a different program
most people who receive the benefit will
be rolled into ei
which has been expanded to include more
people canadians who don't qualify for
ei
but still can't work because of the
pandemic can apply for three new
temporary programs the canada recovery
benefit
the canada recovery sickness benefit and
the canada recovery
caregiving benefit the world is
approaching a disturbing new threshold
in the covet 19 pandemic
as of tonight nearly 1 million people
have died of the virus as david aiken
reports there are warnings the global
toll of this pandemic
could get much worse in the next year
around the world and here in canada
protests against covet 19 restrictions
in madrid sunday thousands in a working
class neighborhood
protested lockdowns that had shut down
businesses
in toronto saturday hundreds protested
mass regulations but public health
authorities in canada and globally
are warning masks and some regional
lockdowns
are vital to what the government of
canada is calling a second wave of
transmissions
we really are at a crossroads with covid
right now the global death count from
covet 19 is about to hit 1 million
and in canada and elsewhere the number
of new cases is on the rise
that has prompted a warning from the
world health organization
that deaths could hit 2 million before a
vaccine is available we look
at losing a million people in 9 months
and then we just look at the realities
of getting vaccine out there in the next
nine months
it's a big chance for everyone involved
indeed that task was the dominant theme
at the just concluded leaders week at
the united nations general assembly in
new york whoever finds the vaccine
must share it this is a global
responsibility and it's a moral
responsibility
for a vaccine to be shared far and wide
almost all leaders spoke to the
near-empty u.n general assembly hall via
video conference
in his taped address indian prime
minister narendra modi vowed that
india's vaccine production and delivery
capacity
will be used to help all humanity in
fighting this crisis
canada's new ambassador to the u.n bob
ray introduced justin trudeau right
honorable justin trudeau
trudeau in his speech said multilateral
institutions like the un
have never been more important and that
global cooperation on vaccine
development is crucial
let's use our shared power not just to
get a vaccine
but to get it out to everyone the
canadian government has already spent
millions of dollars
to reserve millions of candidate vaccine
doses when it comes to that spending to
fight the virus
my message to canadians is we will do
whatever it takes
indeed on monday in the house of commons
mps will debate
new legislation that calls for spending
an additional
four and a half billion dollars on
vaccine research and development
david aiken global news ottawa
in melbourne australia the world's
toughest restrictions
are easy that's because there's been a
dramatic drop in new cases
the state of victoria recorded just 60
new cases in the last 24 hours
down from over 670 at the height of the
outbreak in july
starting tomorrow melbourne's city-wide
nighttime curfew will be scrapped
residents can now return to work next
month primary school students will
return to the
classroom but there will be fines up to
five thousand dollars
to ensure people don't break the
five-person limit on gatherings
in portugal's capital thousands joined
protests calling for the minimum wage to
be increased
and better protection of jobs that are
being impacted by bans on
international travel portugal relies
heavily on tourism
in august unemployment rose above 400
thousand
that's up by more than 33 percent
compared to the same time
last year coming up the political
showdown over donald trump's
supreme court pick
there are calls for calm as a conflict
between armenia and azerbaijan
heats up both nations are on war footing
tonight
accusing one another of reigniting
violence in a long-disputed territory
at least 16 people have been killed and
more than 100 wounded
the two former soviet countries have
been in a standoff for nearly 30 years
over the breakaway region known as
nagorno-karabakh
the territory is inside azerbaijan but
it's been under the control of ethnic
armenians for more than 20 years
separatist factions in the enclave want
independence
with the escalation in fighting armenia
declared martial law
and a full mobilization of its military
azerbaijan's leader says his country
is carrying out a counter offensive
americans can expect a showdown in the
u.s senate beginning
october 12th that's when republicans and
democrats will fight over president
donald trump's nomination for the
supreme court
democrats are concerned amy coney
barrett's confirmation could threaten
abortion rights same-sex marriage and
health care
as jennifer johnson reports the battle
has only just begun
a battle is brewing on capitol hill in
just over two weeks the u.s senate will
consider
nominating judge amy coney barrett to
the supreme court
republicans have the votes to fast track
the conservative judge
angering senate democrats senator mitch
mcconnell who could find no time to
attend the negotiating
on the coronavirus relief package and
yet when this vacancy occurred he
dropped everything now we're going
hell-bent on getting this done before
the election
at stake immediately the high court's
hearing on whether the affordable care
act or aca is constitutional
arguments are set for november 10 one
week after americans cast their votes
for president
barrett has already questioned that the
american people should make no
mistake about it a vote for judge
barrett is a vote to take away health
care
and its protections for over a hundred
and thirty million americans
while conservatives are rallying around
u.s president donald trump's pick
she will defend your god-given rights
and freedoms she will
democrats argue the newly elected
president should pick the person to
replace justice ruth bader ginsburg
a new new york times siena college poll
shows 56 percent of americans
agree but not republicans i don't know
we can make this decision or should i
know we shouldn't make it
based on the politics of it but what our
job is
that new poll also shows democratic
presidential candidate joe biden
leading president trump to 41 percent if
the election were held now
on tuesday night barrett's nomination
will likely lead to fiery exchanges
between biden and trump in their first
televised debate
i'm focused on making sure the american
people understand
that they're being cut out of this
process they're entitled to be part of
and the cutout designed in order
to take away the aca and your health
care
in the midst of a pandemic the
candidates are expected to come out
swinging
with the tax centering on the covet 19
pandemic
racial inequality and the future of the
supreme court
jennifer johnson global news washington
still ahead the caribbean country that
wants to cut ties
with the queen global national is back
in two minutes
you're watching global national
in nova scotia this is the first
installment of street art to show
halifax's solidarity with the black
lives matter movement
the project is part of a broader
commitment by the municipality
to address racism in the region and amid
months of anti-racism protests sparked
by cases involving police violence
against black people the black lives
matter movement is fueling a push to
shed ties with the monarchy in some
caribbean countries
barbados plans to remove queen elizabeth
as its head of state and become a
republic
the island nation has been independent
from british rule for more than half a
century
but as crystal commansing reports its
leaders say it's now time to cut
all colonial ties
[Music]
sparkling clear blue water and beautiful
scenery
this is what many picture when they
think of barbados
and barbadians took another step in
crafting
their own image and future it's not a
divisive decision it's not a decision
that is reflective of any break with the
monarchy
or any disrespect in fact it's quite the
opposite we have an excellent
relationship
with the united kingdom with the royal
family
still barbados is breaking up with the
queen
removing her as the ceremonial
figurehead of the island nation
the news was shared in the speech from
the throne at the opening of the second
session of parliament
barbados's first prime minister the
right excellent errol walton barrow
cautioned against loitering on colonial
premises
that warning is as relevant today as it
was
in 1966 1966 was the year the country
gained independence from britain
for decades there had been discussions
about cutting all
ties with the commonwealth barbados was
one of the
oldest english colonies in west indies
dating back to the 17th century
and slavery was very much part of its
history
recently there have been talks about
colonial tributes such as statues and
street names
and discussions about recognizing the
role slavery had in
shaping barbados and its people
now prime minister mia motley says it's
time for full sovereignty it is
important to us
that we give confidence to our young
people to that little boy that little
girl
to believe that they can become an aspar
to become
the head of state of their own country
other nations such as trinidad and
tobago and guyana have made the leap
the benefits of the commonwealth have
also been debated in jamaica australia
and canada but becoming a republic
is complicated for example in countries
such as canada indigenous treaties
are with the crown and the constitution
sets a balance between provinces
territories
and the federal government so you would
have to get the provinces to agree to
give up
on the crown and ask pei
who is an equal partner to ontario and
federation in our federation if they'll
ever give up the crown
so as an institution for provincial
independence i don't ever see them
wanting to get rid of it even quebec
maintains their the office the
lieutenant governor you don't see it but
it's there
barbados has had two constitutional
reviews and only needed a two-third
majority in parliament to remove the
queen
the official move will happen next
november
in time for the country's 55th
anniversary of independence
crystal gamson global news london
coming up is it an asteroid or something
else
about to enter earth's orbit
a dazzling light display could be seen
in the skies over
parts of finland the northern lights or
aurora borealis glowed for hours
the end of september is a good time to
catch the show which is a result of
electrically charged particles from the
sun
entering earth's atmosphere the natural
light show was also seen above parts of
northern canada
it sounds made up but a mini moon is a
very real space phenomenon
it happens when an asteroid gets caught
in earth's gravitational pull
then temporarily starts orbiting our
planet but one object
entering our orbit later this year is
raising the eyebrows of astronomers
because as mike delay explains it
doesn't look like an asteroid
the mighty centaur is on its path at
cape canaveral nasa fired a lot of
centaur rockets into the atmosphere in
the 1960s
malfunction they didn't all work
out but that was the trial and error
part of the space race
in 1966 a centaur rocket carrying the
surveyor 2 spaceship
malfunctioned close to the moon part of
it crashed
but the centaur spun off into space
never to be seen again
i mean you know we were very um shall i
say
flippant in the 60s with respect to the
the upper stages of vehicles we launched
lots of vehicles to the moon
during the 60s we launched lots off to
mars and to venus
and we really didn't care what happened
to the upper stages
fast forward to the present and
astronomers have found an object deep in
space they named 2020so
in december it will temporarily get
caught in earth's gravity in orbit the
planet
becoming what's known as a mini moon
except
it might not be an asteroid i think you
know what's people's interest and
definitely
my interest is you know the possibility
that this might be
you know a human-made object that was
launched they did the math
lots of math and concluded it was going
far too slow to be an asteroid
so they did more math and determined not
only that it was the same
size as the centaur rocket but that it
was on the same trajectory as the one
they lost in 1966.
in recent years we've seen some amazing
images of asteroids like this one in
2013
that lit up the russian sky as well as
oddly shaped objects like umuamua
that some believe was an alien
spacecraft and of course elon musk added
his own oddity when he launched a tesla
into space
and maybe that will become a mini moon
in the future who knows
it's that unknown that continues to
intrigue us and come december hopefully
we get a clearer picture of our
temporary mini moon
man made or not mike durley global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is 20 mile creek in
ontario's niagara region
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back here tomorrow good night
[Music]
you